la contraofensiva avanza según kiev
Ucrania confirmó la toma de la aldea de
blajo dagne ubicada en el suroeste de la
región de doniesk la noticia la hizo
oficial uno de los portavoces del
ejército
contra la responsabilidad he sido
autorizado a declarar la liberación de
la aldea de blacknet se encuentra bajo
bélica novocilca Esto fue un logro de
los combatientes de la brigada separada
68 jagger o Lexi
estamos viendo los primeros resultados
de las acciones de contraofensiva aunque
sean resultados locales resultante esta
conquista refuerza la teoría del intento
de cortar en dos áreas las zonas
ocupadas por Moscú Mientras tanto Rusia
acusó a Ucrania de atacar su flota Naval
del mar Negro el objetivo era un barco
de reconocimiento se bañado
hoy alrededor de la 1:30 hora de Moscú
las fuerzas armadas de Ucrania
intentaron atacar sin éxito el de la
flota del mar Negro que se encuentra
realizando tareas de monitoreo para
garantizar la seguridad a lo largo de
las rutas de los gasoductos turquez
Stream y Blue flujo en el sureste del
mar Negro por su parte el ministro de
defensa de Rusia
entregó la más alta condecoración
honorífica rusa a varios efectivos
involucrados en el rechazo de los
asaltos ucranianos en el contexto de la
contraofensiva la Estrella de Oro de
héroe de la federación de Rusia fue
concedida a quienes destruyeron tanques
y carros blindados del adversario en los
combates en la víspera el mando militar
ruso publicó imágenes de un grupo de
equipos presuntamente suministrados por
occidente y utilizados por kiev
totalmente destru